welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons Ant-Man on the WASP
quantumania is just right around the
corner and what better way to prepare
yourselves for the big head Kang gang
introduction than by re-watching the
first and second Ant-Man movie but who
has time for all that I did thanks to
spotify's audiobook collection I
listened to Ant-Man and the WASP the
hero's journey if you don't know Spotify
offers a ton of audiobooks on Marvel
heroes like the Guardians of the Galaxy
Captain Marvel and our very own Ant-Man
so I sat down and listened to the junior
novel narrated by McLeod Andrews adapted
by Steve Belling it follows Scott and
Hope from the first Ant-Man movie to the
aftermath of Civil War up until the
second movie Ant-Man and the WASP now
there's a lot of things in this story
that are interesting and we never see in
the two movies there's a ton of
information regarding Sunny Birch
Ant-Man and Falcon's relationship we
hadn't seen so I'm gonna break it down
for you what happens in this novel that
we didn't really see in the movies that
are good to note also I don't believe
this is all Canon but we aren't too far
off from it being true and I'll get into
it here we start the story with Cassie
and Scott hanging out and Cassie asking
about the Captain America story which we
know is her way of saying Captain
America Civil War for us we ended man
with the post-credit teaser to Civil War
where Sam Wilson telling Captain America
I know a guy then picking up in civil
war with Clint Barton opening the van to
reveal Scott Lang hero's journey reveals
that conversation between Clinton Scott
actually looked like this there was no
call no email no nothing just Barton
showing up on his doorstep telling him
that he had to leave with him now
he vouches for you and that's good
enough for me Barton had told him he was
Falcon AKA Sam Wilson
but me
Really Scott had asked what about Hulk
or one of those guys wouldn't Captain
America want a really strong guy
Barton had Shrugged his shoulders
as for you specifically by name he said
you want to question Captain America's
decisions
Scott had shaken his head vigorously
nope nope I'm good with it the beeline
told this story until they merge begins
with Hank pin and hope van diem and
their strained relationship as father
and daughter that we all know far too
well because we've seen the movies thank
put up both his hands Palms outward and
a gesture of surrender I've been a jerk
hope gazed up at the ceiling searching
for the word she wanted to say
it's not about you being a jerk she said
slowly
I notice you didn't dispute the fact
that I'm a jerk the story like all books
can tell you the character's emotion
rather than seeing it on camera so
during the specific scene an Ant-Man
where Scott tells hope he's Expendable
that's why he's in the Ant-Man suit
instead of her hero's journey tells us
what's really behind Hope's subtle
expression oh Patton thought of it that
way
why would she for her entire life all
she knew about her father was that he'd
tried to shut her out of his life the
story bounces back from present day to
flashbacks with storytellings to Cassie
from Scott and it's nice getting these
little memories from the movies like the
retelling of Scott stealing the Ant-Man
suit and his first trial in it the book
does summarize the movies nonetheless
making it easier for you to rehash well
you may be forgotten plus it's just
really cute because he's telling it's a
cassie-like stories he's interrupted by
a phone call with Jimmy Wu which puts
Scott in a tizzy because he doesn't want
this to ruin Cassie's moment right now
it's just time for our daily check-in
I'm in the field on another assignment
so I'm calling it in today
oh okay Scott answered with palpable
relief Wu made him nervous he hoped he
didn't sound nervous but he was pretty
sure that he did
well I'm here at home not leaving like
usual
good Wu replied clearly distracted
because I'd hate for anything to ruin
our Arrangement I'm sure Cassie would
hate it too
you're so close Scott it's only a matter
of time before your sentence is served
as we remember he's currently under
house arrest for the Civil War and
breaking the sokovia Accords now when we
get back to Scott telling Cassie's story
he's telling her about Iron Man kicking
his butt which we fondly can remember
from Civil War it hurts when Iron Man
hits you
even when you're teeny tiny like an ant
Cassie asked see how the black Checker
in her left hand and stared at Scott
with her big eyes
I don't know Scott answered because he
didn't hit me when I was Aunt size I was
big we also remember why Scott loves
Cassie so much and something that's very
important to note as we enter
quantumania is that Cassie has always
been curious in meddlesome his daughter
never failed to surprise him with her
thoughtful insightful questions and
observations about the world around her
Cassie had an incredible Natural
Curiosity embedded in her
she's definitely smarter than I was at
her age her curiosity won't end at the
two-way signal and were interrupted by
Luis who comes in and warns Scott of
Sonny Birch so what do you know about
this guy Sunny Scott asked Louise nodded
vigorously having anticipated the
question he's a bad dude supplies things
that people need for a price and that
price is really high like we're not
talking just money but like blackmail
and secrets and stuff like that you know
what I'm saying I know what you're
saying Cassie said jumping into the
conversation Luis put up his right hand
inviting Cassie to give him a high five
the two slapped hands she's so smart
Scotty Louise said beaming at Cassie
they grow up so fast
yeah they do Scott said in this story
Scott learned of Sunny Birch before we
watched Hope's interaction with him from
the van and Ant-Man and the WASP now we
answer the story where we talked about
Sonny Birch and his connection to Hank
Pym the MCU he had connections with the
FBI and was contacted by hope and Hank
but in hero's journey Sonny and Hank
cross passed during Hank's Shield days
and his reputation precedes him rumor
had it that Sonny used to fence stuff
for Hydra the same organization that
Shield had fought against for years
another rumor was that Sunny was a stone
cold killer unfortunately like in the
movie they needed this part from sunny
and in hero's journey we get insight to
Hope's first encounter with sunny at a
battered grimy Diner it sort of mimicked
the same introduction they had in
Ant-Man and the WASP but in a completely
different location so right here is the
part of the story I really got into I
really like this like I said earlier
Louise warning Scott of Sonny Birch LED
Scott to believe Birch was doing
something bad with Hank and hope he was
becoming paranoid so much so he called
up Sam Wilson for a favor tell you what
caps got something cooking but we might
have a little down time you give me the
information and I'll see what I can do
thanks Sam I really appreciate it Scott
said trying not to sound too hopeful
don't get your hopes up Sam replied
I sounded too hopeful Scott thought what
a
the guy's name is Sonny Scott began he's
a bad guy offense deals in stolen
merchandise but really high-tech stuff
he had contact with a couple of people
from pem Technologies in the last couple
weeks after Civil War Sam and Scott
became good acquaintances and I love the
idea of this because technically
ant-man's First Avenger friend would be
Falcon he met him first in Ant-Man Sam
requested Clint bring him in maybe I
just want everything from this but I
think they're closer than what we see
not only is birch a piece of work but
he's a wanted man the feds would love to
get their hands on him and they're
looking
so anyone you know they're going to get
caught in the crossfire
yeah I figured Scott repeated
listen Sam thanks for this I owe you one
you owe me like 20. Sam said look me up
when you get out Tic Tac this
relationship is something I hope
blossoms more on phase five and six and
I think this book did a good job
exploring it and Ant-Man and the WASP
Scott is having dreams that could be his
connection to the quantum realm in the
movie he immediately calls Hank but in
hero's journey his first call is to
Maggie his ex-wife and Cassie's mother
Maggie could always calm him down
instantly because they've known each
other for so long so their conversation
went like this I want someone to tell me
not to call
to tell me I'm just being ridiculous and
it was just a dream and I should just go
back to sleep
without missing half a beat Maggie
replied
you're being ridiculous it was just a
dream and you should go back to sleep
Scott laughed
set myself up for that he said Maggie's
side
you'll do the right thing Scott
I'd say you always do but you don't
but I know you'll do what you think is
best
thanks Maggie give Cassie a kiss for me
okay Scott said eventually he calls Hank
which like in the movie he leaves a
voice message hoping that they can help
him interpret his bad dreams and that
was it for the thrilling Adventures of
Ant-Man and the WASP Heroes Journey
there's a ton of great audiobooks on
Spotify for you to listen to go on over
there and check them out if you're a
listener like me and work better
listening than reading this is great for
you I also like any form of Storytelling
before bed make sure to follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu underscore
Clemons follow new Rockstar subscribing
to rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]